thank you very much indeed for being
here this morning it is a very exciting
event this morning I do thank you for
your attendance and I very much hope
that you've had a wonderful year Inlet
um this year and that you're looking
forward to your CC experience next year
I just want very briefly to explain the
circumstances and what has gone into the
event this morning for a number of years
now we've been thinking about ways of
trying to bring coherence to the
transition from their time in the first
year to CC in the second year and to
think about ways in which we might
articulate how to bridge the gap between
the two courses and so this morning is
the first event we have actually been
managed to manage to stage precisely to
address that need it is a wonderful
great pleasure to introduce professor
mark Lilly this morning a very
distinguished specialist in intellectual
history focusing especially on Western
political and religious thought he has
been a professor of humanities at
Columbia since 2007 and is no doubt
known to very many of you not just
because of his wonderful teaching but
because of his prominence partly in such
and periodicals as the New York Review
of Books and the New York Times but also
as a distinguished author of such
volumes as the reckless mind
intellectuals in politics which came out
in 2001 and the stillborn God religion
politics and the modern West in 2007 I
just want to say a very brief word about
the Q&A session after the lecture there
are two microphones between the aisles
please if you would wish to ask a
question after the lecture please line
up before the microphones it's just more
efficient to do it that way it's a
wonderful pleasure to introduce
professor Miller addressing us today on
the soldier the sage the saint and the
citizen
thanks for coming in Plato's dialogue
the Gorgas we find Socrates and
discussion with a nasty little man by
the name of calculus who wants to
convince Socrates that might makes right
at a certain point in their discussion
Socrates tells them that their
disagreement isn't really about justice
it's about something even more important
don't you see Socrates says our
discussion is about the way we are
supposed to live and what would even a
man of little intelligence take more
seriously than this is it the way you
urge me toward to be active in the sort
of politics you people engage in these
days or is it the life spent in
philosophy having agreed that these are
two distinct lives it's best to examine
how they differ from each other
and which of them is the one we should
live Socrates is a philosopher and
philosophers make arguments which is
what Socrates does with calculus but
Socrates also embodies the kind of life
he is defending and enacts it as he
speaks and in fact calculus does as well
they are after all fictional characters
engaged in an invented conversation a
drama is skillful and artful as any play
you'll read Socrates not only defends
the philosophical life he enacts it in
speech and the Gorgas Plato lets up lets
us observe what it is to be a
philosopher while simultaneously
considering arguments defending that way
of life in the Platonic dialogues action
and argument are always related but when
the question of the good life
up in the Gorgas they're united to ask
this question which is the best life is
for Socrates at least to answer it now
Plato wrote dialogues rather than
treatises and I wonder whether that's
because he saw philosophy as involving
two activities that could only be
brought together in a drama reasoning
and observing he may be telling us that
you that you cannot reason well if you
don't first observe well and nowhere is
observing more consequential than when
taking up the fundamental question
Socrates devoted his life to how should
I live this is also the fundamental
question of lit home I'm not sure how
many of your teachers have let you in on
this secret or even if they're aware of
it but let me be the first to bring you
the good news you've read a lot of books
this year too many in my opinion and
you've encountered countless characters
in them and all of them even the ones in
the history books are products of an
author's imagination when we meet them
our own imagination is stimulated in
turn and we are almost inevitably led to
think what would it be like to live like
this person or that person what would it
be like to value what they value pursue
their goals suffer their disappointments
experience their happiness whether you
realize it or not you've already begun
to philosophize you've been observing
human nature in action and have even
begun to recognize distinct human types
who represent radically opposed ways to
live so you're now ready to start
reasoning about which of these lives if
an
are worth pursuing and which might be
the best for you or for anyone I'm
guessing that at the end of April you're
not up for that right now you've had a
very long year and everything probably
seems like a blur you're probably not
even sure which books you read
well I sympathize and I'd like to help
so over the next hour I'm going to try
jogging your memory to remind you of
what you've already learned about ways
of life and the people who lead them and
along the way I hope to get you thinking
about the underlying tension between the
alternatives they represent and the
gains and losses those alternatives
necessarily entail so why am i doing
this well because you want me to these
are the things you came to college to
think about of course that's not at all
what you told the admissions office on
your application you figured correctly
that to be admitted you had to exude
confidence about what Americans and only
Americans call their life goals and you
had to demonstrate that you have a
precise plan for achieving them it was
all
you know it I know the real reason you
were excited about college was because
you had questions buckets of questions
not life plans and PowerPoint
presentations talking to my students
I've discovered that they're far less
interested in getting what they want
then in figuring out just what it is
that's worth wanting Americans society
though doesn't encourage you to admit
these sort of things or to take time off
and consider the alternatives at your
leisure and I'm sorry to say not all my
colleagues do either but today you've
got a friend and as friends we're going
to admit to each other that we aren't at
all sure what is the best way to live
but that we want to know then we're
going to think back on this year's
reading and consider some of the lives
we saw represented there and the very
different types of human beings who live
them we're only going to examine four
such characters I'll call them the
soldier the saint the sage and the
citizen but when it comes to ways of
life for is already a very large number
so let's begin
the soldier Achilles is angry he's angry
because he's been dragged into a foolish
war by a foolish general angry because
that fool has taken what's properly his
angry because the superiority has not
been recognized he has very good reasons
to be angry but these reasons are not
the ultimate source of his anger
Achilles is a soldier it's his job to be
angry
aggression is basic to human life and
not just human life as we learn by
watching the antics up on Olympus but
the gods are perfectly capable of taking
care of themselves they don't need
protection we do without the soldier
neither Saints nor sages nor citizens
could survive we need angry people to
protect us from other angry people
political leadership you might say is
the art of anger management and next
year in CC you'll be introduced to how
this art was conceived and practiced
from antiquity to the present living as
citizens in a rich and powerful nation
we can actually avoid thinking about
this problem if we want to we have no
draft or national service to remind us
of it and we can afford to send the
disadvantaged to fight our Wars for us
we in this room are privileged lot which
is why our first encounter with Achilles
is so shocking we prefer to think that
we can live without him
but it turns out we can't do without the
soldier even if what we want is peace in
the lights Estrada Aristophanes uses
base jokes to convey this lofty
political lesson lice Estrada wants to
bring the troops home too wants peace
but she knows there can be no peace
unless she becomes a general herself
in order to end the war she must steal
the money that pays for it to get the
money she must get inside the Citadel in
a storm this Citadel she needs troops
that turns out not to be so easy she's
surrounded by athenian women who are
deprived of citizenship and had no sense
of public affairs
so lice Estrada must transform them into
soldiers which she does in a very comic
way she cajoles she threatens she makes
them swear oaths and it works
she and her troops are much tougher than
their male adversaries more manly in the
conventional sense more committed to the
public good and they win their war
easily another thing we learned from
Aristophanes is that women as well as
men can display these heroic virtues
Herodotus seems to agree as we see in
his story about Queen to Meera's of
masahito which I'll remind you of when
the queen learns that her son has been
tricked and captured by cyrus the great
she doesn't react in a conventionally
feminine way she Stokes her anger and
she goes into battle when her troops
finally defeat Cyrus's army and kill him
she searches and finds his body
she then curses him in words worthy of
Achilles in her rage she addressed his
body as follows Herodotus writes I
warned you I would quench your thirst
for blood and so I shall she then filled
a wineskin with blood and shoved his
severed head into it game over
the soldier is a particular human type
who follows a distinctive way of life
the aim of that life is glory the
closest thing to immortality human
beings can hope to attain on earth and
what brings glory is not victory per se
but the display of certain virtues in
battle even in defeat the virtues of
Honor courage and loyalty no soldiers
were more glorious to the ancient Greeks
than those who lost the Battle of
Thermopylae where they were vastly
outnumbered by Persian troops as you
recall knowing that the battle was lost
spartan king leonidas ordered the armies
to retreat and to ensure their safety he
stayed at his post with a small
contingent facing certain death when a
scout sent by Xerces spied on Leonidas
his troops he was surprised to discover
this that the Spartans were not biting
their nails or praying to the gods they
were doing the morning exercises and
combing their hair serene and the
knowledge that by doing their duty
honorably and courageously they could
attain eternal glory when Xerces heard
this he laughed but after the battle was
over he wasn't laughing anymore he had
lost a great number of men he had
learned Herodotus tells us that although
he had plenty of troops he did not have
many men
it's hard not to admire the soldier and
his virtues but all virtues had their
characteristic vices and the soldier's
vices are as destructive to society as
his virtues are to protecting it if the
soldier is the most necessary human type
he is also the most dangerous when his
anger is misdirected honor becomes
vanity courage becomes hubris and Duty
becomes vengeance how many examples of
perverted anger and twisted virtue did
you read about Oz fall Achilles dragging
Hector's body around Troy Clytemnestra
staging Agamemnon scat murder a style
G's making her pages eat his own son sir
cease flailing at the waters of the
Hellespont and then Alcibiades sailing
off to Sicily now after reading these
stories many of you having grown up in a
Christian or post Christian society come
to the conclusion that anger itself is
the problem that anger itself needs to
be extinguished but is that really true
even from a Christian standpoint you
also read the Gospels and you know that
when Jesus entered the temple and saw
the money changers he did not greet them
with a blessing he made a whip and he
used it on them kicking over their
tables and driving them out the guide of
the the God of the Bible is full of
righteous anger and sometimes so is his
son the Prince of Peace
and it's a good thing too when Rosa
Parks refused to move to the back of the
bus in Montgomery Alabama in 1955 she
said her feet were tired but she was
also angry and her anger set an example
for other African Americans who in their
struggle for civil rights displayed the
very same ancient virtues that the
Greeks admired in their soldiers they
defended their honor they were
courageous and they did their duty even
in the face of bombings beatings
lynchings water hoses and German
shepherds if you recognize their
nobility then you must recognize the
nobility of the soldier the story of
stories of Queen Tamera's and Rosa Park
Parks teach the very same lesson no
anger no justice
now every civilization has classes of
human beings like soldiers whose job is
to regulate our relations with each
other historically most civilizations
have also reserved a place for those who
mediate between ourselves and what lies
beyond the human realm though they go by
different names some places he's called
a shaman others an Oracle prophet high
priest monk nun Reb a Sufi Bodhisattva
let me call all of them Saints in every
culture Saints hold a special kind of
insight into man's place between the
divine and the animal world's and
they're living exemplars of that wisdom
through their piety its piety and not
the soldiers honor that is the Saints
highest virtue and defines his way of
life for the sage the summit of Wis
wisdom is the adage know thyself for the
saint it's know that place
now the Saints we encounter in the Corps
come mainly from the Abrahamic tradition
of Judaism Christianity and Islam these
Saints live under the authority of a
very distinctive kind of God he is the
one and only true God he is a creating
and redeeming God and he is a revealing
God who speaks to us the God of the
Bible is not the remote silent God of
some religious sects nor is he always
hanging around and getting in our hair
like the Greek guys
the Bible's God is transcendent and
discursive though he created us we are
not his chattel he talks to us we talked
to him and were free to obey Him or not
of course if we want a good life and
also a good afterlife we must obey Him
all religions value righteousness but
the Bible prizes only righteousness
conditioned by obedience we actually
don't know if Abraham was righteous
before God chose him all we know is that
he responded to God's call we also don't
know why he was chosen and were not
meant to know the lesson of the call and
of the near sacrifice of Isaac is that
Abraham trusted the Lord and obeyed him
simply because he was God when God
decides we must accept trusting in him
why does the Lord prefer Abel sacrifices
to Cain's who knows why does God love
Jacob and hate Esau don't ask and what
about poor job the victim of a cruel
barroom bet between God and Satan this
very strange story which is not a Jewish
story seems included in the Hebrew Bible
to make one thing perfectly clear that
there is has a protestant feel
and later put it an infinite qualitative
distinction between God and man job is
already a righteous man but
righteousness in the Bible is not enough
it must be accompanied by recognition of
God's sovereignty Jobe only becomes
truly pious when he prostrates himself
before God's greatness I uttered what I
did not understand things too wonderful
for me which I did not know now my eye
sees thee therefore I despise myself and
repent in dust and ashes a soldier would
never say that and neither this age but
a christian saint would last of all you
explore the differences between the
Hebrew Bible and the New Testament and
you discovered what what Nietzsche later
called Christianity's great revaluation
of values in Christianity Hebrew piety
was transformed from faithfulness to a
covenant between God and the people to
individual deciced
discipleship based on choice and this
choice brings with it as we see in st.
Augustine an inner struggle between two
wills one good the other evil but the
highest virtue of the hebrew saint
righteous obedience is not altered by
jesus christ nor is it's often God's
cruel demand that Abraham murder his own
son is matched by Jesus's cruel demand
that if anyone comes to me in debt and
does not hate his own father and mother
and wife and children and brothers and
sisters yes and even his own his own
life he cannot be my disciple
the Saint accepts this even rejoices in
it by knowing his place in recognizing
his dependence he lives the best life
possible for human beings against the
soldiers anger the saint is righteous
and compassionate forgoing honor and
glory he's humble he liked this soldier
prizes good life a good life over a mere
life but that's only because he
recognizes something higher than human
life the soldier however brave and
honorable he may be does not what makes
him a hero is that his sacrifice can
never fully be redeemed even in glory as
Achilles laments in Hades Oh shining
Odysseus never try to console me for
dying
I would rather follow the plow as thrall
to another man one with no land allotted
him and not much to live on than to be
king over the parish dead the soldier
loses his only home in death the world
the Saint even in the world abides in
God late have I loved you
Augustine writes beauty so old and new
late have I have I loved you you touched
me and I'm set on fire to attain the
peace which is yours I can find no safe
place for my soul except in you
the Saints life is in the end not fully
of this world which raises a number of
questions what is the saint oh the world
and what is the world oh the same you'll
be discussing this all next year in CC
and I think they'll discover that the
only thing harder than governing a
nation of sinners is governing the
nation of saints this age the soldiers
virtue is this play is displayed in his
actions his actions are honorable or
they're dishonorable the Saints virtue
is displayed in the principle behind his
thoughts in action that principle is
pious or it's in pious the sages virtue
on the other hand is displayed in what
he knows he's wise reason now many
societies ancient and contemporary the
true sage is thought to be the same
since he bussines his wisdom from on
high but acquiring wisdom is not the
Saints aim in life wisdom is either a
byproduct of his righteous obedience or
it's a gift bestowed on him by the
divine the sage on the other hand
pursues wisdom entirely on his own
either because it helps him achieve
other ends or because he sees wisdom as
an end in itself in fact this year
you've encountered both kinds of sage
one who draws lessons from worldly
experience and uses them to guide his
actions in the world the other someone
who questions his experience and
discovers not practical lessons but his
own ignorance and with this with wisdom
finds a new way to be in the world
I think the highest form of practical
wisdom that we encounter in late hum is
political wisdom and most of it concerns
how to cope with the anger aggression
and pride of the soldier Exhibit A
Agamemnon
while Achilles is pouting in his boat
and the Greeks are losing battles
Agamemnon tries to inspire his troops by
using reverse psychology he gets up on a
pedestal and he tells him he's giving up
he's going home and he somehow expects
this to rouse their defiance and
fighting spirit a child could have
predicted what happened next their cries
hit skyward as they made for home Homer
writes if you recall it then fell to
Odysseus and Nestor whose experience had
taught them a thing or two about human
nature and they found a way to keep the
troops from fleeing they accomplished
this through a kind of doublespeak
the foot soldiers they threatened the
officers they flattered knowing that
these different kinds of human beings
are motivated by different things that
never would have occurred to the mighty
hegemon not just as the soldier can
suffer noble defeats so can the
political sage so lon you remember tries
to convince Croesus that the tyrants
life is the unhappiest of all but
Croesus refuses to listen and has to
learn the bitter lesson by experience in
his funeral oration Pericles tries to
inspire public spiritedness in selfish
Athens by praising them and their
democratic regime is the best on earth a
few months later the plague strikes and
the city falls into what the acidities
calls a state of unprecedented
lawlessness
the most successful political sage we
encounter turns out to be a goddess
Athena who uses the occasion of arrest
Jesus trial to innocence refound city of
Athens
she clearly sees in the predicament of
arrestees the two countervailing goods
are at stake on the one hand with the
Furies called the voice of a jeweled
wisdom is in fact not wise at all since
all it does is inspire an endless cycle
of blood bloody revenge on the other
hand though the Furies irrational but
primeval rules train Athenians to
recognize that certain things are sacred
and therefore not subject to the Caprice
of human laws and so at the trial Athena
not only exculpate s' arrestees she also
gives these angry ones these gloomy
children of the night the proper place
and Athenian society in the private
rather than the public realm she then
turns justice over to the courts she
strokes the Furies egos while at the
same time disempowering them she's
clearly learned a lot from living with
those prima donnas in that failed state
called Olympus
Socrates on the other hand learns a lot
by living in Athens but his wisdom is
expressed in a very different way in a
symposium you've seen that Socrates
sense does not hand out lessons based on
his experience he asks questions about
other people's experiences and in doing
that gets them to expose their reasoning
there there are some lovely speeches on
love in the dialogue especially that of
Aristophanes but play of it socrates
shows his friends one by one that they
had no idea what they're talking about
if there's nothing malicious and what
Socrates does he's not like your
graduate student section leaders he
wants to get at the heart of the matter
but also demonstrate through his
comportment what it means to be devoted
wholly to the pursuit of wisdom but how
did Socrates get this way well he gives
an account of himself in the apology a
dialogue you unfortunately weren't asked
to read this year and which should be at
the top of your summer reading list it
seems that one day the Oracle of Delphi
declared Socrates to be the wisest man
in Athens which Socrates knew to be
absurd so he went out to speak with his
fellow citizens politicians poets
craftsmen sure that he'd find someone
wiser than him but he didn't professing
themselves wise if they proved to be
fools which made Socrates realized that
he was wiser than them if in only one
respect in his words that what I don't
know I don't think I know such a simple
thought
but a revolutionary one since as
Socrates is modern disciple Montaigne
put it nearly 2,000 years later all the
abuses in the world are engendered by
our being taught to be afraid of
professing our ignorance Socrates and
Montaigne look about them and they see
exactly the same thing that people are
unjust towards others and unhappy within
because they have false ideas about what
truly matters it's not that no one has
revealed the truth to them or given it
to them like a present it's that they
lack a certain orientation toward life
that allows truth to reveal itself and
it's by watching Socrates speak with
others that we learn what it is to have
such an orientation now who could
possibly object to a life like this well
lots of people it turns out that is why
in the apology Socrates is on trial for
the capital crimes of not believing in
the city's gods and of corrupting the
young inconsiderate from the standpoint
of the saint or the soldier you can
understand why he's on trial a pious
Athenian who falls into Socrates his
hands will soon realize he knows nothing
about the gods he worships and a young
man going to war who listens to him will
soon lose the anger he needs to be
victorious in battle it turns out that
the pug-nosed busybody socrates in fact
does threaten the foundation of the
Athenian political order if Athens is to
continue as it always has either he must
cease philosophizing it in public or he
must die he chooses to die which means
he also ceases to philosophize but he
leaves behind an example of a life
wholly devoted to truth
what's not explored in the apology is
the road not taken' that Athens rather
than Socrates be made to change what
would it be like to have a city in which
the philosophers wisdom was follow after
Socrates is death played a wrote the
Republic an imaginary dialogue in which
a city is built from scratch with an eye
to letting philosophers rule when you
read it next year you'll discover
something odd but very revealing that
the discussion does not begin with the
training of the perfect philosopher it
begins with training perfect soldiers to
protect the perfect philosopher
the citizen the soldier the saint and
the sage are human types who can be
found in every civilization the citizen
cannot by citizen I don't mean the
citizens of ancient Greeks de
city-states were also something of a
novelty I mean those of us who for a
little over two centuries now have been
living in bourgeois societies governed
by representative political institutions
that guarantee basic human rights and
where individuals are considered free
autonomous creatures you can call this
person modern if you like though the
term does inclined people to think of
the citizen as the culmination of some
historical process and therefore the
other three ways of life i've described
as belonging to a lost world that cannot
and should not be recovered and in fact
that's exactly what the thinkers who
promoted the citizen as a human type
want wanted us to think and they're on
hangs a tail the kind of thinking and
writing that helped shape the bourgeois
citizen was consciously directed at
something that only existed in the West
and that's Christendom in its Roman
Catholic and then Protestant
incarnations
now why was christianity Christendom a
particular problem well consider these
two verses in the New Testament that you
read in the Gospel of Luke Jesus tells
his disciples the kingdom of God is
among you but in the Gospel of John he
says my kingdom is not of this world so
which is it well the Catholic Church
refused to choose it claimed authority
over both the spiritual City of God and
the terrestrial City man
and in so doing as its credits critics
charge it distorted every noble way of
life
the Honorable soldier was supplanted by
the ruthless Crusader who conquered and
murdered the infidels the monastic Saint
was overshadowed by a politically
ambitious Pope and by bishops who enrich
themselves by selling tickets to heaven
and the so called theological sages
wrote tome after learning tome speaking
presumptuously about God's will and
dictating behavior in his name now from
the 12th century down to the president
there have been reformist elements in
the church that recognized these
abominations and work to correct them
from within but for others let's call
them humanists reform was insufficient
because the problem lay deeper not only
in the church but in the other ways of
life were examining to the soldier the
saint and the sage these ideals simply
aim too high and by pursuing them human
beings become more like beasts not more
like gods what the world needs was a
less ambitious more decent ideal of life
that also would be attainable by
everyone away a life attempt it adapted
to how most people really are and not
how they should be the best way of life
for these new thinkers is the most
realistic way of life
one of the most effective weapons in the
humanist campaign turned out to be humor
never underestimate the power of a joke
a mocking laugh can do more to undermine
an idea than libraries of books refuting
it I can think of no more devastating
critique of Roman Catholicism not in
Luther not in Calvin not in Voltaire
then those wickedly funny stories in the
de Cameron all Boccaccio has to do is
point out the enormous gap between the
saintly life the clergy professors and
the selfish gluttonous over sex lives
they actually lead his work is done the
more we laugh with him the less
seriously we can ever take the same day
life Cervantes achieves something
similar in don quixote he creates a
character whose mental illness is
precisely idealism idealism his self is
what he suffers from Cervantes doesn't
really mock the heroic virtues of Honor
courage and duty and I think he means us
to love Quixote it's just that the world
is simply not good enough for Quixote
and in life you have to adapt to the
world you have and not the world he'd
wish for now granted is not as much
humor in Montaigne as arisen Boccaccio
or Quixote but his tenth intent in the
essays is exactly the same as theirs to
clip the wings of our ambitions and
teach us our limits except Montaigne
also redefines those limits by painting
a disarming disarmingly modest portrait
of himself as he supposedly really is
he's very happy to admit that he's an
imperfect man that his happiness rests
entirely on being reconciled his
imperfections whether they're physical
mental or even moral
an unwillingness to accept and live
within the limits of the human is the
source of all devices Montaigne most
hated devices that were on full display
in the religious wars of his time
superstition fanaticism cruelty cruelty
to the self and cruelty to others and
domination by the strong and by example
he shows us a new way of living based on
new sorts of virtues this way of living
depends on self-acceptance pleasure
spontaneity moderation
skepticism self-sufficiency variety and
above all an acceptance of mortality
Montaigne admires Socrates as perhaps
the greatest of men but he derives from
the fact that all men are not Socrates
the lesson that Socratic philosophy must
be abandoned so he writes a new kind of
philosophy one men for the rest of us
who aren't Socrates the book Inlet hum
that best reflects the kind of world
Montaigne dreamed of is to my mind Pride
and Prejudice to begin with is a
realistic novel a relatively new
literary form that allowed writers to
explore human psychology and behavior as
they actually manifest themselves in
daily life it also in the spirit of
realism turned its eye to a way of life
that had been passed over by almost all
wet Western literature until that point
and that's the domestic lives of women
a few pages Enterprise Pride and
Prejudice we realize that we're reading
up about people who have nothing to do
with the elevated human types I
discussed earlier the soldier has been
replaced by the gentleman and ladies the
Saints piety replaced by good manners
the sages wisdom replaced by common
sense and the immortality of the soul is
replaced by the inheritance of property
Darcy is an honorable man because he
keeps his word
not because he dies like Hector mr.
Bennet
well he's wise in a practical way he
understands his wife and his daughters
and how to cope with them but he's
bitter and incurious
especially about himself mr. Bennet does
not do self-knowledge and Elizabeth is
obviously no saint so she's not a sinner
either instead over the course of the
novel Lizzy has to learn the bourgeois
virtues of the citizen to be more
skeptical about her own moral
certainties and more tolerant of the
variety of human characters she becomes
a good person not a pious one she would
not respond to a divine call if she
heard one and would politely do more if
asked to drop everything and follow the
Lord she's much too sensible to run off
in pursuit of an ideal that's what Lydia
didn't look what happened to her no
Lizzie will stay home she'll take care
of her sisters he'll raise a family and
she'll pass on her property to her
children that is the best one can hope
for in human life and she will have
achieved it and Payne would have loved
this book
but one of the curious things about the
modern citizen or modern citizens is how
many of them are dissatisfied and
unhappy in the bourgeois world they've
created for themselves yes they're
comfortable they're safe they're free
but they keep asking themselves is this
really the best way to live is this all
you'll spend a good deal of time
thinking about this bourgeois
disenchantment in CC next year after
reading some philosophers like ninten
who worked very hard to create a world
tailored to human limitations you'll
then read authors who find the bourgeois
citizen not even human Rousseau will
complain that in becoming civilized and
polite the citizen has lost his natural
goodness Tocqueville will worried about
the inner emptiness and anxiety of
isolated individuals in a democratic
society Marx will denounce the inhuman
economic exploitation that makes the
citizens life possible and Nietzsche
will call him the last man a creature so
debased and lacking in grandeur that
only a heroic regeneration of the whole
species could possibly redeem him now
this debate over the bourgeois citizen
which is run on which is run
uninterruptedly from the late 18th
century down to our time doesn't explain
explicitly as a debate in any of the
works you read this year but Bush why
disenchantment does it's the pivot
around which to the lighthouse terms the
fate of the last man is not Virginia
will steam the red in a certain light
the novel does convey a certain
wistfulness about living in a world
where realistically there are no
soldiers no saints
and know sages the feeling the courses
through the book is that of relatedness
of living after after the one big thing
of having mist which truly matters in
the novel Achilles is nowhere to be
found
the Cataclysm of the First World War is
only alluded to even though the book is
in fact an allegory of how this Caesar a
transformed European consciousness it's
only in the short interlude that we
learned that Andrew actually went to war
and was killed we don't know why he went
what he felt about it and what he wanted
to do there we don't know we witnessed
no mourning no gnashing of teeth no
tearing of garments no funeral orations
the horses do not weep for Andrew as
they did for Patroclus all Virginia
Woolf gives us are two parenthetical
sentences about his death a shell
exploded twenty or thirty young men were
blown up in France among them Andrew
Ramsey whose death mercifully was
instantaneous
that's all Andrews death has no higher
meaning nor do we find a sage in the
novel mr. Ramsay is a philosophy
professor not a genuine philosopher and
while his disciple Tansley thinks he's
Socrates
Ramsey knows better philosophical genius
only appears once in a generation if
that and he was not the chosen one
well he did all right he figured out how
to get from a to Q he had a good innings
but he long ago gave up hope of reaching
Z and now he's honest with himself he
had to admit he'd never reach our he
likens himself to the leader of a doomed
expedition
and there are no Saints into the
lighthouse though Lily Briscoe and mr.
banks would love to canonize mrs. Ramsey
but in truth she's just a projection
screen for their own psychological needs
and fantasies seen through our eyes mrs.
Ramsey appears as an ethereal soul but a
rather abstract it and self-involved
mother she loves her children but she
can't imagine them ever being happier
than they were then when they were
infants in her arms why must they grow
up and lose it all she wanders in the
lyrical dinner scene she prepares an
elaborate meal for her loved ones though
her thoughts are not on their pleasure
or nourishment they are on the perfect
visual tableau she is created for
herself
and which is ruined when her young
daughter takes a perfect pair from the
perfect fruit bowl and takes a big bite
out of it how odd that ones child should
do that mrs. Ramsey muses
though we witness no mourning for Andrew
lily is inconsolable at the loss of mrs.
Ramsay she dreams of her she sees her
image in the summerhouse but by the end
of the novel she and we begin to see
that this ideal like all the other
others must quietly be put to rest
ideals are illusory things they loom
over us and keep us from living in the
here and now mrs. Ramsay must be allowed
to pass just as Lily's painting must be
finished it's not perfect
nothing is so give the canvas that one
last stroke stroke of the brush and put
it aside it's time to move on that in
the world of the citizen is a summit of
wisdom
but is it the last word read for the
first time to the lighthouse offers a
modest and very English sort of
consolation yes too bad isn't it that
the lives of soldiers saints and sages
are no longer possible pity that still
it does keep us from building up any of
those harmful illusions and we certainly
don't want people feeling disappointed
no that wouldn't do better to recognize
that everything is what it is and not
another thing and there's an end to it
but reading the novel at the end of a
year inlet hum it leaves me at least
wondering whether this is wisdom or just
whistling in the dark what is for so
threatening about the prospect that yes
you actually can still lead a life of
valour or piety or wisdom I ask myself
which is the more mature attitude to
take to assume that the tides of history
have made our choices for us that all
the elevated aims that inspired people
for centuries no longer have meaning
that all we can hope to do is reconcile
ourselves to being free individuals
without any particular idea of what we
want to do with our freedom or is it to
face up to the fact that history never
changes anything that modern freedom has
if anything heightened the drama of
having to choose among irreconcilable
ends because traditions and taboos and
families no longer determine our
destinies as they once did that I think
is part of the anxiety you feel and why
you try to cover it up by sounding so
self assured about your life goals and
career choices you know that you can go
to law school but you also know that you
could just as well devote your lives to
the defense of your country to the work
of your churches and synagogues and
mosques or to proving some theorem
that's never been proven what you want
and need to do is choose well
and now after year Inlet hum I think
you're in a better position to do just
that every year at the beginning of term
I look around the classroom pause and
then tell my students this is the most
important class you will ever take I
hope now you understand why thank you
the floor is open for questions why
don't we give a pause take a moment's
pause while while the already wise leave
us
okay let's start with the first question
hi so I had a question about your your
reading of to the lighthouse I'll do
what so you're reading up to the
lighthouse and I might have misheard but
you mentioned the conclusion there are
things essentially are themselves things
rest in themselves they they aren't
other things in what chapters this I was
going to quote the book to me Wow
Oh Noble in Chapter nine of the
lighthouse with James we see that James
looked at lighthouse he could see the
whitewashed rocks the tower stark and
straight he could see that it was barred
with black and white he could see
windows in it he could even see washing
spread on the rocks to dry so that was
the lighthouse was it no the other was
also the lighthouse or nothing was
simply one thing nice nice so I'm and
partially because I'm trying to write a
paper about this but I'm interested in
your thoughts and also there's that
passage earlier and the in the window
when mrs. Ramsey is sitting by herself
and she thinks about how other things
things outside would then oneself
express one things become one they they
actually are one drop of your thoughts
Benson yeah very nice very nice thank
you for that yeah there's a contrast I
think and we're meant to feel the
contrast between James and Lily James is
the unreconciled one he has seemed
unreconciled since the beginning of the
novel when he's playing at his mother's
feet he's unhappy and he's always angry
and his whole life in a way has built up
to this trip which should be some
dramatic event to offer catharsis and it
turns out just to be a trip to the
lighthouse
the kids are pouting because they didn't
want to go on the trip they can't quite
find the lighthouse then they find it
they hear some fisherman died
go up there the game sandwiches and it's
just slow deflation like a tire but
James still won't hold on still won't
let go the idea he sees the lighthouse
he finally gets there and what he does
is then displace it somewhere else
there's another one to go to so James is
cut out of the cloth really ah that also
tailors the soldier the saint and the
sage but I so there's a tension between
James and Lily but I think that the mood
at the end anyway is that Lily will
never forget mrs. Ramsey but she'll go
on with her life now if you've been
taping that unit is right in your paper
is that anything is that good okay
thanks
yes hi professor I have a question about
how you look how you perceived the Ross
County curve in crime and management do
you think that he's a saint or a soldier
what is he looking for what kind of
Justice is he seeking yeah I was
dreading that question actually
we get a perverted sense of sainthood I
think in not only rush colony cough and
not only in other characters but
especially in the way rush colony cough
looks at others he thinks he's superior
either because he's wise or potentially
saintly his superiority like that of
Achilles is not reconciled and like
Achilles he withdraws he goes up to his
little room but then his character moves
in a way that Achilles has never would I
think and that is to make a gratuitous
act a kind of rebellion at the way
things are so that definitely makes him
not at all the bourgeois citizen right
I'm not sure what it makes him but
what's interesting is that like so many
of dusty of skis characters the most
depraved ones are all seeking Saints and
so you're meant to feel that there's a
relation somehow between these two that
I've never quite figured out or been
able to put into words sometimes there's
a kind of redemption as in a way there
is it this book they're in there in
Siberia together but I guess the
Dostoevsky I prefer is the one who
doesn't reconcile this that he's that
one idea I think that keeps recurring in
the novels is that oh and one of his
favorite novels was Don Quixote he
called it the saddest book ever written
and his characters in a way are Don
Quixote is without the jokes there in a
world that isn't good enough for them
and we don't laugh at that we rather see
that people who are too good for the
world do terrible things because the
world does not respond to them and
whether you're looking at the devil's or
you're looking at the idiot or you're
looking at crime and punishment
you always dos cfcs analysis of evil or
some kind of evil arises out of the gap
between the saint and the way we live so
how did you Rachel I was hoping you
would talk more about Rousseau and where
he fits in one of the four types or it
seems like he transcends all four of
them you would please talk more about
that I'd love to hear it well they
hadn't read Rousseau yeah yeah no no I
don't love it
I'll give them a foretaste okay Rousseau
is in the position of someone who thinks
that our goodness is natural and not
acquired we don't become good by
becoming a soldier as a saint or sage
but through some historical accident
human beings have fallen into society
civilized society and in order to
survive in it you have to be alienated
from yourself in your natural goodness
and be very attentive to what others
think of you
the problem in Rousseau and what makes
him stand out is that he has this view
of history that history removes
possibilities from us so he thinks the
natural life is no longer possible what
do you do well he writes two works to
figure that out I think only one of them
you read and that's the social contract
in which he imagines an ideal Republic a
little like Plato does in the Republic
and it's a kind of thought experiments
not meant to be taken as seriously as
people take it I think as literally he
then writes his greatest work which I
try to teach every couple years in which
I may teach in your junior senior years
which is immune which is a story of an
ideal education what if you were to take
a young man before he's corrupted by
society and have an ideal tutor raise
him out in nature
how would he turn out and how it would
here en true society that I think is the
key to understanding both Rousseau's
disappointment and his aspiration
Merlin um I had a question about your
understanding of Don Quixote
um you say that Cervantes kind of mocks
don't go hotei to say that he's kind of
in competitive slower slower I could I
um it's almost as if you say that
don't cojones idealism makes him
incompatible with his society that um we
need to live in a world which um in
which our values align and that Don
Quixote values really don't align with
his society but I think we kind of see
um especially in the priest in the
barber kind of the opposite the priest
is the character that really tries to
cure Don Quixote that recognizes his
illness tries to purge him of this but I
think that um even the priest exudes a
lot of idealism we see this when the
priest tried to get rid of all Duncan
hoodoos books in his library he finds
that some books are too great throughout
and especially at the end of the novel
when when Don Quixote says that he's not
actually don't go hook to anymore
the priest and the barber all both beg
him to go back on his expeditions to not
abandon his idealism and then at the end
of the novel um after Don Quixote dies
the priest puts Don Quixote is both
natural name and his idealistic name on
his death certificate meaning that both
of them kind of they want that idealism
and realism or one in the same so do you
think that idealism is kind of an
undertone and that society or do you
think that Don Quixote is really
incompatible with the society oh that's
great
well it's true that there are characters
that seem to have managed this
you mentioned the priest in the barber
maybe the scholar I forget his name also
is like that but the novel doesn't teach
us how to get from Quixote to them we
don't get an explanation on how to hold
on to a certain ideal but in a moderate
way in society so it's problematized in
Quixote is I think not chivalry in
particular but rather someone who
pursues this ideal Singh
mindedly so it's the single-mindedness
that were meant to look at and it's in
looking at the single-mindedness that we
see the gap and the gap is there a
couple gaps I think one is that one of
the problems with chivalry is that it's
not real honor chivalry is a kind of bad
mix of Greek military virtue and
Christian charity and Christian love
yeah
so it's an incoherent ideal that Quixote
can attain but that shows up in his
behavior but the ideal he still he
understands he he embodies another ideal
actually which is that he's generally on
a genuinely honorable courageous and
dutiful so we get a critique of a bad
idea and get an example of what a real
ideal might be by the way he is but he's
unable to do that because he's been
struck by this bacillus of chivalry
which is a bad one and so it makes a
fool of himself but in the end I think
the gap is shown in Cervantes but I
don't think that the lesson and I hope I
didn't give that impression is give it
all up it's rather meant to make us feel
the comic tragedy in this position and
to learn to love Quixote yes
hi I've always sort of been confused
about why wait hum is called
masterpieces of Western literature and
philosophy when all of the philosophy
books are taught in CC or most of them
and I sort of was glad to hear this
lecture because it sounds it sounded a
lot like a like a peace treaty between
literature and philosophy finally
showing what they're all what they're
what each of them are getting at but now
I sort of wonder if there is some
benefit to the to the war between
literature and philosophy like isn't it
problematic that literature even as it
shows us different possibilities to live
it doesn't justify them first
it works different from philosophy it
just shows us the saints the sages the
citizens but it doesn't explain how they
got to be that way
or whether they sat down and considered
whether they should be that way
and isn't that a fundamentally different
way of even approaching the question of
how to live then philosophers would take
that it's we don't decide we just do it
and then we observe it afterward and may
be imitated right and when he you
mentioned a meal before I mean a meal
was a novel what a meal was thought to
be a novel at first I think because it's
a story of how this person got this
ideal education just as much as it's the
rationalization
so what maybe do you think that would
hum and CC should be taught if in an
ideal world as one long class or whether
they should be different ways of
of thinking oh yeah I actually don't
think it matters much I mean if they're
all taken together but I was hoping for
a question like this actually for a
couple reasons one is the question you
began by saying we're only reading
Western works and one of the points I
hope came through though I didn't
address it directly is that the human
types and I mentioned the first three
appear in some form in all civilizations
and that the tension between those types
is greater than the tension between
cultures that is there is more tension
between a samurai and a Buddhist monk
then there is between a samurai and a
crusader or a Buddhist monk and a
Catholic monk so that you by studying
any civilization and looking and
observing these types you start to learn
the same sorts of lessons not that you
don't want to get the variety that's why
I think God there's a world cultures
sequence now but the point I want to
make is that you can abstract the
Western is out of lit hum to get it
something more fundamental but the other
point you make is a point that Socrates
makes and for that I simply point you to
the apology you'll read about this
problem in the Republic where Socrates
bans the poets you've also seen it a
little bit in the symposium
Aristophanes creates this beautiful
image and Socrates never address
addresses directly Aristophanes they're
sort of battling in actually in Greece
he writes a play about Socrates it may
have led to Socrates his trial mocking
him
but Aristophanes is the best in creates
this beautiful image of love
Socrates then goes on to criticize
someone else
Aristophanes is about to speak and
Alcibiades walks so we never get to hear
what the poet says then in the apology
when Socrates goes out to find out who
the real wise men are he goes out first
and meets a politician and is clear they
know nothing about what they're talking
about at the end he meets a craftsman
and discovers that craftsman know one
thing but they think that one thing
applies to everything and then there the
poets the poets perceive everything they
absorb everything they're perfect
receptors and they're able to turn it
into an image what they can't do is
reason about it and that's why I think
the way to replay dough is as an
improved kind of poetry you'll see this
in the Republic at the same time that
Socrates is banning the poets he's
rewriting Homer and gives a kind of
cleaned up philosophically sound Homer
for his interlocutors to take away so I
think that at least in Plato there's an
awareness of what this tension is that
kind of awareness gets lost certainly by
the time we come to modern philosophy
thank you
could you furthermore discuss the theme
of redemption in crime and punishment is
a full reinsurance into normal human
relations possible for Ascona golf and
how historians what possible a full
reentrant into normal human relations
impossible for Raskolnikov and how do
you feel that Dostoevsky handles this ok
that's good too well he ends the novel
with them out there and in a sense
dramatizes this problem that appears in
also in quixote
that maybe these people can only live in
isolation and that the redemption will
be spiritual but it won't be social that
there's no way to redeem this
relationship if you summer I suggest you
read the idiot where you'll find the
characters in precisely this condition
he's never reconciled with society he
sort of walks through it like a dream I
don't think that OCSP holds out for a
redemption of the kind you're talking
about it's a very gloomy man Oh over
here forgive me for reading off my phone
I wrote my question about so as not to
lose my head in the face of public
speaking you revealed four human types
the soldier the saint sage and citizen
Raskolnikov separates humanity into
ordinary and extraordinary you seem to
say that it is possible to transcend a
model of a citizen that seems robotic or
at least dilute but how do you suggest
that we do this with no Trojan War when
the saint is a laughable figure within
the capitalist model when the sage is a
marginal figure disconnected from the
central fierce fear of politics
how can we do this without being as
laughable as Don Quixote pursuing higher
ideals at a time that is past okay you
read that very fast so now I'd like you
to summarize it without looking at your
phone it's so I can answer you also
possible how do we transcend the ideal
the idea of this robotic and dilute
citizen to become you know the saint the
sage the soldier or the citizen in a way
that isn't as laughable as Don Quixote
trying to assume these in a time where
that is no longer valued well the the
option that our society gives you is to
do it privately and that the works
you've read were written at times when
that was impossible
except with one exception and maybe
being a private saint or going as an
individual to be a soldier because you
want to be all you can me or working on
a math problem privately that these are
the closest one can come whereas these
earlier ideals also imagined a
transformation of society that would
brought about by whatever wisdom or
virtue or valor that was there so you're
on your own to do it but that doesn't
mean it's dead
yeah the one exception to that is when
you get to the republic there's a part
where after they build this city and
speech this ideal city one of his
interlocutors says so why don't we live
in it
and Socrates then the dialogue dips down
the curve to explain it and Socrates
says in the meantime that that for the
ideal city to arise that would have to
be a miracle if there's no miracle all
the Philosopher's can do he says is
leaned against the wall while the storm
brews around him so Plato
I think envision and envision envisage
this kind of private life when it can't
be transposed to society I'm afraid if
only got one more question I'm told so I
guess I mean with the first three types
well with all four types there's a
problem of perception and that's how I
sort of reacted to what you were saying
in that with the first three types it
was that their aspirations were too
grand
and with the reaction of the citizen
their aspirations are too small that
they can't think beyond the present and
you know I definitely share your
admiration for Montaigne and Jane Austen
for being sort of so acutely aware
ignorance right and I guess well the
first thing is is that there must be
some kind of dynamism to this patent the
mass of human thought if the citizen can
be a reaction in a time scale that it
came later so how do we interact with
that ignorance when we become acutely
aware of it or at least aware of it at
all
like Montaigne did in a sort of effusive
way do we expand into it do we let it
frame ourselves I'm just curious about
that yeah yeah well Mon 10 has one
answer to that question I talk to you
I'm at the end of teaching a year-long
seminar on Montaigne and yeah it's a
complicated answer and I don't think I'm
satisfied with it I have to say but not
the soldier will yes even the soldier
does the soldier the saint in this age
have a response to ignorance and that is
the soldier says I just obey that's my
job my job is to stay angry they point
me at what I'm supposed to attack and I
go in the Republic the the soldiers are
portrayed as kind of gnarling dogs at
the end of a leash sort of pit bulls and
they've been trained to sort of lay down
and roll over when citizens walk by an
attack anyone who's not a citizen so the
soldier says I don't have to worry about
this down Saint says he doesn't have to
worry about it either I mean he's got a
direct access to whatever he needs so
God will give him what he needs to know
but I'm contemplating his ignorance he
also contemplates his dependence on God
and therefore his bias
Socrates has another way of coping with
our ignorance but what you get with
Montaigne I think is a sense that in
reality all those fail and not fail in
the sense that oh you know again game
over but rather that failed
spectacularly and caused tremendous
hardship and make us less human and so
the trauma of the religious wars sort of
was the backdrop to a whole stream of
thought much of which we'll study next
year from Montaigne down through Hobbes
and Locke that sees idealism as such I
use the term loosely idealism as such as
the problem and they don't contemplate
really how you can make a society that's
safe but still cultivate this kind of
striving professor Lilla can I just
thank you as one of the audience thank
you for such a rich complex wide minded
and penetrating discussion of the segue
from the lip term to CC on behalf of the
Lipton community thank you so much thank
you